[Musique]
mais
bien bonjour chez vous aujourd'hui nous
sommes au centre de moscou sur la rue de
fère sky à l'une des principales artères
de la capitale c'est par cette avenue
que les tsars lé prince russe entré au
kremlin venant des territoires du nord
depuis les temps anciens on y trouve les
plus belles maisons les hôtels les plus
luxueux et les boutiques à la mode mais
le quartier autour de la terre ce qu'aia
abrite aussi de nombreux lieux de
divertissement en particulier les
célèbres théâtre moscovite
l'un des plus prestigieux et le théâtre
académique musicale de moscou qui porte
le nom de deux célèbres m de scène
stanislas qui est nemirovitch dantchenko
formé en 1941 c'est l'un des théâtres
européens les plus modernes réputé pour
ses ballets et opéras
notre invité d'aujourd'hui s'appelle
laurent hilaire il est danseur étoile à
l'opéra de paris il est directeur
artistique de balai dans ce théâtre
allons faire sa connaissance
[Musique]
l'eau c'est légal ça me fait plaisir moi
aussi je peux pas imaginer mais quel
honneur d'être dans ce théâtre
magnifique de saab skieurs moi ce qui
m'intéresse surtout c'est d'avoir qu'est
ce que toi tu fais ici mais je me suis
posé la question c'est arrivé par hasard
parce que j'ai un directeur l'ancien
directeur du théâtre directeur général
qui est venu à paris pour me parler et
le moi je pensais que c'était pour
remonter un ballet j'avais déjà quitté
l'opéra déjà remonté des balais mais
imaginez que l'on puisse me proposait
une direction d'une compagnie de 110
danseurs directeur artistique d'une
compagnie russe ça me paraissait
invraisemblable et donc c'est ce qui m'a
proposé et je lui ai dit je lui ai dit
et anton mais à partir de quand
éventuelles et on dit à partir de demain
ça se passe comme ça ici alors je suis
arrivé simplement deux mois après j'ai
fait je suis venu deux fois à voir la
compagnie et j'ai vu qu'il ya du
potentiel c'était un beau théâtre avec
un beau lieu de beaux espaces un théâtre
fait beaucoup de possibilités techniques
et surtout un potentiel artistique avec
la compagnie qui est vraiment qui m'a
vraiment intéressé puis j'avais du désir
des danseurs y avait il y avait une
envie y avait une attente y avait
quelque chose je me suis dit c'est un
projet qui peut se faire alors j'ai vu
combien de temps que tu es là maintenant
ça fait trois ans et demi maintenant 15
ans et demi au moins trois ans et demi
et donc non quatre ans et demi 84 ans et
demi ça passe plus vite que je ne laisse
que vos quatre ans et demi et tu es venu
ici qu'est ce que tu as apporté quelques
changements il ya eu images essayer
d'apporter tu vois on voit sur sur sur
ses cadres de nouvelles productions en
tout cas offrir au public russe et d'une
manière aussi parallèle avec la
compagnie offrir un répertoire qui
puisse à la fois nourrir les danseurs
est aussi intéressé public à travers de
nouvelles propositions moi je suis de
formation classique donc les grands
ballets du répertoire je les aime je les
défends tu connais des je suis un paria
côté de ça il faut aussi vivre avec son
époque et contemporain ça veut dire
balle est aujourd'hui quoi alors
aujourd'hui à la fiche on a fait cette
première hier de roméo juliette avec un
donc tout le monde connaît remis à
juliette shakespeare à la musique de
prokofiev louis et les répétitions
aujourd'hui s'il y avait répétition veux
m'y emmener allez on y va aller vers
d'apporter juste la super
[Musique]
quel homme
[Applaudissements]
et
alors roméo et juliette c'est une
institution suire c'est presque
obligatoire
obligatoire non mais en même temps roméo
juliette c'est moins emblématiques et et
en termes de balai y ait beaucoup de
balles est sûre au maire juliette pointe
et fait parce que c'est les noms un
thème universel c'est l'amour c'est le
corps et c'est donc là j'ai fait une
nouvelle version normale juliette avec
un jeune chorégraphe de 24 ans il fait
partie de la compagnie donkey et russes
pour moi aussi c'est important de
promouvoir les jeunes danseurs russes et
est donc et j'ai associé ce jeune
chorégraphe avec un metteur en scène qui
s'aggrave le constantin bogomolov qui
est très
célèbre ici reconnu qu'un expérience et
donc la jonction entre les deux c'est
une forme d'alchimie qui pouvait ne pas
fonctionner c'est toujours délicat quand
on a une idée on met les gens en contact
ça fonctionne mais jusqu'où ça peut
aller donc j'ai eu quelques moments un
peu en tant que directeur initiateurs du
projet quelques manches musée ou là ce
que ça va vraiment marché et finalement
je pense qu'ils sont arrivés à présenter
quelque chose d'assez unique d'assez
d'assez particulier ait jamais vue
ailleurs quoi dans une proposition c'est
toi qui a choisi le chorégraphe c'est
toi qui choisis le metteur en scène
absolument je construis les spectacles
je fais la programmation et avec qui
danse mais occupe de savoir quels sont
les danseurs qui vont faire tel rôle etc
je gère l'ensemble de la de la
production de a à z est une pièce comme
ça ça se ferait pas en combien de temps
écoute là on a fait à peu près ça c est
allé un peu sur un an un an à peu près
une année mais en général entend propres
pour une création comme ça si le minimum
c'est un mois et demi deux mois de
répétitions mais à temps plein ah oui
c'est que tu répètes sept heures par
jour 7,8 heures par jour avec les
danseurs en permanence donc et cinq
jours voire six jours sur sept et si on
travaille 6 jours sur 7 d'accord en
france et l oms a annoncé deux jours
deux jours par semaine alors après avec
ça peut changer d'un jour de repos fixe
et mobile là c'est un jour c'est un seul
jour par semaine
[Musique]
il se passe des fois où tu t'es tu
lances le projet et les compagnies d'un
petit peu réticente finances a pas
marché on n'y croit pas ou tu tues tu
peux avoir déjà des relations de feu
comme ça suit son père y aura des
problèmes a dit au revoir non mais tu ne
trouves confiance ils me font confiance
mais si tu veux chaque pas papa 110
danseurs à 110 personnalités différentes
à partir de là il ya des il ya des
affinités plus ou moins grande en
fonction du style il ya des gens qui
adhèrent à certains si un ado qui
adhèrent moins
ceux qui restent dans des productions
nouvelles c'est ce qu'ils adhèrent mais
en général puis ce qui est intéressant
c'est aussi par le travail d'arriver à
les convaincre ce que j'essaye de faire
tu sais quand tu as des chorégraphes
nouveau arrive je mets beaucoup de gens
pour les auditions c'est à dire que
voilà il propose il travaille que le
chorégraphe qui a pris un choix qui est
fait ils sont pas tous prix mais ça leur
apprend déjà quelque chose et la fois
d'après ils sont nourris de ce qu'ils
ont vécu avant pour pouvoir peut-être et
je vois des danseurs qui à la base était
des danseurs purement classique dans le
côté très classique et avait du mal à
sortir de ce carcan qui finalement
évolué et arrive à se nourrir d'autres
choses et à être pris sur des créations
qui sont tout à fait contemporaine donc
je me dis là j'ai fait avancer le
schmiblick comment dire français j'ai
fait avancer les choses résultat est là
finalement et j'ai résultat est là mais
il le mérite parce que c'est eux qu'on
travaillé
et après moi je suis là pour gérer et de
faire que les choses puissent se passer
je vois ici des magnifiques danseuses
elles font partie du spectacle écoute ce
sont les quatre juliette de cette
nouvelle production à les quatre les
quatre 4 danseuses quatre personnalités
un peu différente et quatre propositions
et chacune à leur manière des juliet
parce que c'est ça le truc c'est
incarner les juliette telle manière
c'est pas simple prochaine distribution
faut un peu d des profils par rapport à
un certain rôle
donc il et quand je dis profil c'est au
sens figuré bien sûr c'est aussi une
sensibilité quel que soit donc il faut
qu'il y ait une correspondance il faut
que le public puisse y croire c'est
difficile de trouver justement les
bonnes personnes il c'est toi qui sais
toi qui tend au cul ou celle c'est le
metteur en scène c'est le chorégraphe
comment ça se passera enfin ces gens
parlent avec le chorégraphe une
évidemment mais la décision finale c'est
moi qui la prends parce que c'est des
jeunes danseuses c'est aussi il ya des
conséquences aussi sur l'organisation
donc tout ça il ya quand même un
principe de réalité dans une compagnie
sert à la fois il ya ce côté artistique
à la fois ce côté pragmatique si je mets
quatre danseuses et que je n'ai plus
personne derrière pour faire les autres
productions parce qu'elles sont pris ça
pose aussi un problème de structure et
d'organisation
[Musique]
quel a été ton premier contact avec les
avec les russes qu'ils écoutent la
première fois je suis allé en studio
parce que je les connaissais pas donc je
n'allais rencontré la compagnie les voir
travailler pour voir s'il y avait
quelque chose qu'on pouvait faire en
simple et en fait dans le premier cours
ils s'étaient déchaînés il sautait dans
tous les coins sa part fait partout il y
avait une énergie folle moi ça m'a fait
ça m'a fait éclater de rire parce que
c'était tellement sympathique et en même
temps il y avait un tel savais pas si
j'allais devenir directeur ou pas mais
il y avait cette interrogation donc ils
ont fait le show quoi et moi j'aime bien
les gens qui font chaud
[Musique]
bon
son propre pédagogues mais de temps en
temps laurent vient voir nos répétitions
il clarifie certains détails fait
quelques corrections et exprime ses
souhaits
il supervise le projet pour que tout
soit prêt si détaillées et musicale
et à chaque fois il nous révèle nous les
danseurs d'une manière différente je ne
sais pas comment il le fait mais il y
arrive toujours avec une approche
personnelle pour chaque danseur
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que tu répètes l instant là je
répétais avec quelques danseuses étoiles
le rôle de la sylphide qui est un ballet
d'un chorégraphe français qui s'appelle
pierre lacotte donc je répétais avec
elle c'était la première répétition pour
se souvenir un peu des pas des attitudes
des positions donc c'était une mise en
bouche on va dire le vrai travail va
commencer après tu danses toi même tu
participes aussitôt fait non pas que aux
répétitions mais aussi sur scène non non
non non moi j'ai fait quelques petites
choses qui ont été des accidents ou des
propositions à la question fait de
manière pas volontaire de ma part moi
j'ai terminé avec la scène et non là
c'est vraiment tous les grands ballets
classiques ce ne sont que les danseurs
de la compagnie qui dansent et dans
roméo juliette hui un rôle oui j'ai un
petit rôle mais c'est un saint c'est un
couple alors s'appelle elle et lui c'est
un couple âgé alors est ce que chacun
peut y voir ce qu'ils envient d'ivoire
est ce que c'est un couple qui assuré
que l'amour est ce que l'amour on peut
durer longtemps fin voilà chacun peut
voir les sept espèces de métaphores dans
le mais voilà elle aimait ce rôle était
prévu dans le scénario est simplement
après en discutant sur les distributions
qui allez faire quoi le chorégraphe et
metteur en scène m'a demandé de le faire
tu as envie le faire aussi quelque part
écoute c'est amusant parce que j'ai
retrouvé un peu des automatismes pas sur
scène y ait des choses c'est comme le
vélo tu oublies pas et en même temps les
années ont passé mais la chorégraphie
est adapté non j'ai pris du plaisir mais
je veux pas faire ça non plus trop
longtemps j'ai vraiment maintenant c'est
la transmission qui m'intéresse sinon
après au cours des répétitions -treize
donc tu prends toujours du plaisir ça
reste un merci oui tu sais mais voilà je
me mets en tenue un peu de travail un
peu vous voilà avec mais je bouge je
montre un peu si tu es tu restes un
petit peu en forme à une manière
relative c'est pas comme avant tu fais
la barre le milieu thales exercice
pendant une heure et demie le matin je
fais plus à d'ailleurs j'en ai pas envie
très honnêtement c'est la barre la barre
j'ai fait des bars pendant 40 ans dans
ma vie
ça suffit ça signifie que place aux
autres maintient bien médias lâche là
bas on lâche là bas tu vois ce que je
veux dire on navigue à vue ne relâche
pas
laurent hilaire est né en 1962 à paris
dernier d'une famille de quatre enfants
son père est chef de chantier et sa mère
est femme au foyer la famille déménage
gennevilliers où laurent commence très
tôt la danse rythmique puis la
gymnastique très doué il participe même
aux championnats de france de
gymnastique dès l'âge de 8 ans après un
nouveau déménagement à epinay sur seine
les parents de laurent l'inscrivent à un
cours de danse il est vite remarqué par
son professeur celui ci propose aux
parents de laurent de le présenter à
l'école de danse de l'opéra de paris où
il est accepté à l'âge de 17 ans il est
engagé dans le corps de ballet de
l'opéra de paris en 1985 à l'issue d'une
représentation du lac des cygnes il
atteint la consécration en étant nommé
danseur étoile par rudolf noureev alors
directeur de la danse
laurent danse alors tous les ballets du
maître russe dont la bayadère le dernier
ballet de noureev il interprète
également les pièces néo classique de
george balanchine roland petit ou encore
angelin prejlocaj notamment le parc
l'eau on est aussi invitée régulièrement
dans des compagnies étrangères
prestigieuses comme soliste après une
riche carrière de danseur étoile il est
nommé maître de ballet à l'opéra de
paris qu'ils quittent finalement en 2014
après deux ans pendant lesquels il
travaille comme maître de ballet
indépendant pour plusieurs compagnies
dans le monde laurent est invité par le
directeur du théâtre académique musicale
de moscou pour y prendre les fonctions
de directeur du ballet leur en a deux
filles juliette elle même danseuse à
l'opéra de paris
valentine professeur de pilates
noront où est-ce qu'on est ici ici on
est chez moi c'est mon appartement c'est
le théâtre qui m'a qui loue cet
appartement pour moi quand je suis
arrivé l'avantagé c'est que je suis je
suis à deux minutes interminables
minutes à pied ouais ouais c'est
vraiment très pratique et ses
appartements très agréable fonctionnel
mais j'y passe pas beaucoup de temps
parce que je passe je pars le matin vers
9 10 heures je reviens le soir il est
11h 10 en heures donc finalement et que
le lit qui est utilisé à la finalité
wayne un petit peu quand même je t'avoue
que au niveau cuisine je pratique pas
beaucoup et cuisine je fais beaucoup
livré voilà je me débrouille un petit
peu haché célibataire mois ci un
d'accord ta famille vie reste
qui vit qui vit à paris à gérer les
enfants qui sont à paris j'ai ma famille
ma maman qui encore à paris donc voila
et des cercles d'amis s'est réellement
que autour du du théâtre où tu as
d'autres amis dans d'autres non c'est
des personnes que j'ai rencontrées soit
qui venaient voir les spectacles soient
qui sont dans la communauté française
j'ai des contacts aussi avec l'ambassade
biens tout un je trouve qu'à l'étranger
quand même bien il ya un cercle quand
même de gens qui se côtoient alors c'est
pas c'est pas sectaire mais c'est juste
le plaisir de se retrouver dans ce
contexte différent pour partager un peu
les les expériences les émotions et mais
principalement c'est lié avec le monde
du spectacle moi je vis toute la journée
dans le théâtre donc
voilà dans le monde de la danse j'ai des
amis là il ya sept danseuses qui vient
du mariinsky qui s'appelle d'achat par
l'inca je veux dire j'ai passé ça fait
un mois et demi qu'on travaille ensemble
et c'est devenu une amie parce que c'est
humainement et artistiquement c'est
formidable c'est avec elle que tu danses
sur scène oui c'est ça donc ça crée des
liens et évidemment après on se frotte
et oui tu sais quand tu es sur scène que
tu joue un rôle quand même très intime
quand même d'une façon au fond un
échange une émotion quand même très
sincère je vais te planter à quelques
centimètres du visage d'une personne et
que tu peux lire dans ses yeux qui ne
réciprocité dans une forme de connexion
ça crée des liens quand même
[Musique]
tu parlais de ta famille donc de
t'accompagner en france c'est ce qu'elle
vient te voir de temps en temps si elle
est venue bien sûr qu'elle est venue et
mais depuis le comité c'était quand même
un peu plus compliqué spécialement
depuis que la russie est en zone rouge
verser les rapports et c'est aussi une
partie de ma vie aussi qui est un peu
voilà tu fais une forme de sacrifice
aussi et là je travaille et c'est
formidable sur avis en même temps en
termes de vie personnelle de vie privée
vie familiale c'est quand même un peu
plus compliqué
ils ont du mérite ouais franchement ils
ont du mérite parce que c'est pas facile
d'accepter d'être séparés comme ça tu
vois là ça fait un mois et demi deux
mois que je suis pas retourné à paris
donc j'ai pas vu ma compagne des enfants
ma famille donc c'est un c'est un peu
c'est un peu c'est pas simple ton rythme
quand tu reviens en france à 7
correspond à quoi tu ris tu retournes
tous les 3 mois 6 mois c'est maintenant
j'essaye de revenir avec le co vide
c'était je suis resté pendant six mois
donc c'était très compliqué non j'essaye
j'essaye là cette année je voudrais
essayer de revenir une fois par mois
quoi si je peux y retourner
régulièrement ça va je suis pas en
manque je suis pas j'ai pas de moments
quand je suis ici investi de mon travail
où je me dis ou dans ma vie quotidienne
que la france me manque mais les proches
moment et donc j'ai besoin aussi tu sais
quand je vais dans ma maison ensuite de
la france j'ai besoin de me retrouver de
me déconnecter d'oublier un petit peu
vraiment tous les problèmes tout ce
contexte est aussi bien sûr et du
plaisir c'est pas que des problèmes bien
sûr mais vraiment de faire le break donc
je vais un peu c'est comme un peu les
foules et fois je vais dans mon jardin
touché j'adore les oliviers toucher les
oliviers je le regarde voilà ça me fait
du bien ça me ça me ça me régénère il ya
besoin de ça je pense que c'est très
simple avec les oliviers c'est ça ouais
j'ai des oliviers dans le sud je fais
m'ennuie lamont tu fais ton nuit là
ouais je fais mon huile d'olive et quoi
savoir oui oui je te ferai gut s est pas
non mais c'est un truc c'est formidable
quoi parce que tu
tu as ta propre huile c'est ta
production bon c'est un truc un peu
c'est mais moi j'ai ce rapport à la
terre qui est très fort quoi ce rapport
mais pierre c'est des vieilles pierres
c'est une maison qu'il a achetée il ya
20 ans qui était
pratiquement une héroïne qu'il a fallu
tout reconstruire c'est une espèce de
long cheminement comme ça et mais j'ai
besoin de ça pour moi c'est très
important peut-être trop d'ailleurs
quelques fois
dis moi ça fait quatre ans et demi que
tu vis en russie ouais est ce que ta
vision a changé sur les russes
j'avais pas une vision
de toute façon négative au départ mais
j'étais pas non plus je m'attendais pas
à rentrer arriver dans une culture
totalement différente j'étais curieux de
voir comment ça allait se passer mais
dans le quotidien as les choses sont
tout à fait
normal quoi qu'est-ce que tu
conseillerais des gens qui viennent
travailler en russie alors peu
quels conseils tu pourrais leur donner
fait les choses simplement c'est quand
je suis arrivé je me suis dit voilà si
ça marche je reste si ça marche pas je
m'en vais je pense qu'il faut pas
essayer de se positionner d'avoir de se
donner une façon d'être je pense qu'il
faut simplement être naturel et sincère
communiquer avec eux et puis ça marche
enfin voilà et et ça ne ça ne peut que
marcher et des rapports de travail avec
dans ce monde là sont proches est ce que
tu y vois une différence peut-être avec
ce que tu avais auparavant je pense que
la différence c'est moi qui ai c'est moi
qui vais pas changer mais je me suis un
peu détendu aussi peut-être j'ai appris
en tout cas
[Musique]
l'heure tourne et le spectacle va
bientôt commencer les trois coups de
théâtre vont bientôt retentir
[Musique]
les cheveux c'est important aie semaine
brouillonne lorient qui avait moins de
cheveux quand il était à l a51 et tout
ça il faisait crêpés ses fruits car ils
s'adonnent au volant - à l'époque ça me
faisait un peu peur gentiment mais
maintenant c'est mon tour
si bob walsh ainsi
maman tu vas te réchauffer maintenant
non je passe le maquillage maquillage et
unifier un bulletin
et très léger c'est l'évidence avant tu
sais à l'époque il ya les crocs
maquillage avec des traits et comme ça
tous les côtés plus ouais mais c'est
plus extrêmes c'est une époque voix les
gestes je
prêterai puissant fort maintenant on
peut faire c'est un peu plus minimaliste
un peu plus naturel
[Musique]
on est à penser à trois minutes du
spectacle promis quoi que on attend
d'attentats salle soit presse et puis on
y va on attend thoune des frais ça bouge
autour de toi 3 comment je me sens après
toutes ces années de
encore le trac écoute j'ai jamais été
très clair moi j'ai des fourmis n'y
avait pas non mais une tension il ya une
pression et tout ça mais c'est juste
super g c'est d'être pragmatique c'est à
dire que y'a un moment c'est au moment
de faire les choses qu'il faut agir et
avant avoir le trac s'énerve et se sert
pas à grand chose mais j'ai jamais été
trop à coeur non plus porter mais ils
sont pas tristes incarnons ils ont pas
une nature certains puisque d'autres
peut-être mais franchement c'est plus
lent fusée asthme du spectacle l'époque
que la peur d'eux l'appréhension le trac
comme on laisse j'ai senti aussi limpide
il ya une famille
non mais ils sont tout aussi away
vraiment c'est très simple c'est vrai
que nous les raids alliés un monde entre
danseurs puissent parler qu'il ya de la
compétition il n'y a pas de secret
j'aime pas le mot familiale parce que
maintenant chacun fait son travail dans
les prières ya un truc qui se passe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
laurent est une immense figure dans le
monde du ballet et j'étais très nerveuse
il est très facile de travailler avec
lui et je pense que nous partageons les
mêmes valeurs sûres ce qui est important
dans l'art
et c'est un point très sensible
et autocars c'est sur cela que se
construit le partenariat et la confiance
sur scène
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que selon toi la france
pourrait apporter à la russie
pas d'un point de vue culturel je pense
que qu'est-ce qu'elle pourrait apporter
à la russie surtout garder le contact
garder ce lien cette relation forte il
ya
les russes sont vraiment un
grand respect et un amour de cette
tradition française de la culture
française et je trouve que je le ressens
très fortement ici et je pense que c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut protéger et
nourrir à la fois et qu'est ce que
finalement la la russie pourrait
apporter à la france bat et là la même
chose je dirais la même chose je pense
que je pense que tu c'est la grande
question aujourd'hui c'est est ce que
chaque pays avec sa culture perd un peu
de son identité est ce qui est un mixage
un petit peu des cultures je pense que
ces cultures doivent échanger se nourrir
en même temps sans pour cela se perdre
parce qu'il ya des identités très forte
donc que les échanges continuent
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui t'a le plus surpris en
russie
l' enthousiasme
l'entousiasme bas principalement dans
mon travail ici avec les danseurs la
disponibilité l'envi le désirent et puis
l'envi de l' envie de faire confiance
qu'est-ce qui continue de tâtonner
il continue à me faire confiance
laurent ça m'a fait énormément plaisir
et très je suis très honoré d'avoir fait
ta connaissance de t'avoir vu sur les
sur les planches reste un plaisir de
vous avoir ici de vous accueillir ici
une bonne continuation en tout cas merci
yade merci a bientot merci au revoir en
famille
[Musique]
et voilà notre émission touche à sa fin
nous l'avons passé avec laurent hilaire
qui nous a fait découvrir les coulisses
d'un grand théâtre moscovite de nouveaux
lieux de nouvelles personnalités toutes
aussi intéressantes vous attend je vous
dis à très bientôt sur arte france
[Musique]